welcome to exploring computing
today's video is creating web pages
adding images so this is going to be
part of a continuing series where we
take a look at how to add different
elements to our web pages
previously we saw how to create links
between our web pages and
that's certainly critical because as
we've talked about the thing that really
makes the web the web is that hypertext
and so
if you've watched those videos you now
know how to do that but
while those links are great our if all
our web pages have on them as text
that's going to be pretty boring so in
this
video we're going to talk about how to
add images to our web pages
it turns out that there's a fair number
of options and some subtleties here
which may not be obvious
so we're going to go through the
different options and how to get
everything to fit together
i'm going to start off with this image
from venice that you've seen previously
from the first week
and this is mostly going to be our
example image although there are a
couple images we'll see along the way
okay so here's how you're going to add
the image to your web page
there's an img tag notice that the
closing slash at the end of the img tag
indicates this is a standalone tag there
is no start and end tag
and there's an src property or source
property
this is a url and it can be
a relative or an absolute reference i'm
using a relative reference which you'll
recall
from our discussion on links means that
this venis.jpg image file is in the same
location as the html file that
is referring to it and then you're
supposed to have an
alt tag alt tag is information used
for a variety of different purposes most
notably
to increase accessibility by those who
may not be able to see your web page and
are using screen readers which
read the web page to them instead of
viewing the web page
it is required if you do not have an alt
tag
you will have an illegal html file
okay so just using the img tag as shown
here this will put the image on the web
page but
the next question is how does this image
relate to the text around it and this is
where things get a little bit messy
so what i've done here is i've added
some extra text here so this img tag
and the text that is all um in my html
source file
uh as far as the lorem ipsum goes here
this is randomized text from cicero's on
the ends of
good and evil and it's commonly used as
placeholder text
for design work so you'll see this in a
fair number of places if you start
trying to learn how to do design
and so we're just going to go ahead with
this traditional traditional
random text okay let's take a closer
look at our web page here if you look
down
in our zoomed in view here and look at
the relationship between the image and
the text
you'll see that the text comes down not
below the image but
actually alongside the image so this
looks a little bit odd and i think the
way i
like describing it is it's as if the
image were a giant
letter so like let's say you wanted to
have a giant l
there this is what the image is doing so
we're going to use the letter
o and uh here's a diagram where i
created a giant o
and you've all probably seen those fairy
tales where they've got once upon a time
and that o is really big
and so here's my big o here
and then if i go ahead and have that img
tag
followed by the once upon a time
you can see that this image acts as a
gigantic o
so as i suggested it's like the image
acts as a gigantic character
and just to emphasize that this is not
something that just occurs at the
beginning of the line
here i've used my image in two places
and you can see that
each time my image has
ended up looking like a gigantic o in
the middle of our line of text
so this is probably not what you want
so let's go back to our venice image
here and we're going to try and correct
this
there's a couple different options i
think
one of the more interesting ones that
you are likely to need if you've got a
web page of any complexity
is something called float okay so let's
go
let's go back to our uh image event here
i'm going to start using some style
rules for how to control how
venice or venice images appearing on the
web page the first thing i need to do
though in order to get this to work is
i need to add an id to venice so let's
go ahead and do that
i could also use a class i suppose i
could write a rule that applied to all
image tags remember we have those
type selectors so i could write a type
selector that applied to all images
but that may not be the best option uh
we'll have a separate video where i
go over an extensive example and we can
talk about these different options for
now
i'm just going to go ahead and give my
img tag an id i'm also going to increase
the number of paragraphs of ipsom lures
just so we've got a little bit more
interesting text to work with
all right so i'm going to go ahead and
add a star rule for the venice id here
so remember that's the number sign
venice to use an id selector whereas it
were a class selector i would use a dot
and then i'm going to use this new style
property we haven't seen before called
float
and as you can see here float floats the
image to the left side of the web page
and the text flows alongside of it
it's quite different than what we saw
before a minute ago where the image was
acting as a gigantic character
now it's clearly an image floated to the
left side of our web page and so
as i mentioned a little earlier this is
a great technique
that you can use on a lot of different
web pages
and then of course there's a float right
that moves the image to the right
so one issue that comes up is where does
the image actually appear and what you
need to do here is you need to list the
image
before the text you want to flow
alongside of it
previously i listed the image first
followed by the paragraphs
and that put the image alongside the
very first paragraph again the first
paragraph was listed below the image in
the actual html source
now i'm going to move the paragraphs
so i have the first paragraph before the
image and then the second paragraph
after the image tag and so you can see
that i've done that here and when we
look at the
result you can see that sure enough the
image floats alongside
the second paragraph because the image
appears before
the second paragraph so remember image
needs to be listed
before the text it's going to float
alongside and then we can actually stick
the image in the middle of
the paragraph as well and so here that's
what i've done here you can see i've got
the paragraph and i've sort of
highlighted where the paragraph starts
and ends
and um let's take a look at that word
there i have no idea how to pronounce
latin but i'm going to claim it looks
it says dewis that appears immediately
after the img tag and if we look
at our image you can see that sure
enough that word appears
roughly after the start of the image so
basically the web browser is trying to
get it as close
as possible to the image without
having a huge massive blank space there
so
you can kind of play around with it but
it it it does seem like um
i know many students find this behavior
a little bit odd just remember
you want to have that img tag before
whatever you want alongside of the image
all right let's go ahead and take this
back to our first
example where we did the float left now
if we're looking at the
float left here and we look at what the
web page actually looks like you'll
notice that
there's an awful lot of crowding between
the photo and those words alarm ipsum
that clearly does not look right we
really want some space there
and we can go ahead and do that by
adding a margin so here i've added a
margin of 15 pixels
and this actually gives us space on the
right where we were really noticing we
have a problem
it's a little hard to see but there's
also space on the left side of the photo
and on the top and the bottom of the
photo so when we say margin 15 pixels
we're saying put a margin around
the entire image on the top bottom left
and right
we can control this individually as well
if we want so i'm going to go ahead and
set the margin on the right to 30 pixels
i'm getting rid of the overall margin so
my 15 pixels on the top bottom and left
are gone
it's a little harder to tell that the
top and bottom are gone i think if you
look closely
you can kind of tell that the 15 pixels
is gone on the left
there is a little bit of slight space
still left there by the web browser
um and so the basic point here is i can
control
each of the four margins individually
notice that the way it works is
margin dash followed by the specific
margin
as opposed to left margin right margin
it's margin right
margin left margin top margin bottom
okay it turns out that margins are just
one
of several different properties related
to what are called box properties
box properties allow me to put boxes
around elements
and so the box properties are the margin
the border which we'll take a look at in
a minute and then the padding
these work not only on images
but on any block level element so if you
want to put a margin a border and a
padding around a paragraph
you totally can do that and in fact this
can give you some nice effects so for
example if you've got a block quote
and you want to float that and put a
margin around it that is totally doable
all right so let's take a close look at
our border our padding and our margin in
this example i've set border padding and
margin
i've set a 10 pixel solid blue border a
10 pixel padding and a 20 pixel
margin and okay the border is pretty
obvious
although it's going to turn out there's
a bunch of subtleties to that
what's the padding the padding is the
space between
the image or whatever element that
you're using the box properties on
between the image and the border
and then the margin is the space between
the border
and whatever surrounds the image
all right let's take a closer look at
the border as i mentioned this
this has a little bit of subtleties to
it okay i've
combined three different properties here
into a single line
but we can actually separate border 10
pixel solid blue
into three individual properties border
widths
10 pixels border style solid
border color blue order width and border
color
are pretty obvious um the solid
you can sort of work that out like
that's a solid border okay sure
um so there's actually a whole bunch of
settings for border styles let me just
really briefly mention too you can have
a dashed line you can have a dotted line
mostly what i want to emphasize here
though is you need to have a border
style
oddly the default border style is
none so if you say hey i want a border
that's 10 pixels in blue
the web browser is going to be like i'm
sorry
that's great you want that i'm not
displaying a border because
the default border style is none so you
have
a non-existent 10 pixel blue border have
fun with it
so remember to have that border style
solid
or the fancier options like dashed or
dotted whatever
but you do need to have a border style
if you just provide
a color and a width you will get nothing
it's super annoying
all right let's look at our other
options here so i've been floating the
image
that works great for a lot of purposes
but maybe you don't want that
maybe you want the image to show up by
itself with paragraphs above and below
it
well the first thing to remember is
let's go back to our original attempt to
just stick an image onto our web page
before we did the float okay remember
this is what we got we're treated as a
giant character
okay that's not what we want um
one possible solution here is one of the
issues
why this is being treated as giant
character characters because the text
following the image is not in a block
tag so
if we go ahead and put our paragraphs
into paragraph block tags
then we can go ahead and get this effect
here i've got a paragraph
before the image i've got a paragraph
after the image
the paragraphs are explicitly blocks and
then between the two blocks i get the
image
and this seems to be what i want
but there are a couple problems but
before i move off of that
notice i've gotten rid of the style here
and i've got that slash
asterisk no style use slash asterisk
what the heck is that
well obviously part one i'm trying to
tell you
yeah i'm not forgetting the style sheet
there is a style sheet there and there
is
no style used but the question is like
what is this star stuff this is what
it's referred to as a comment
this will show up in html it will show
up in
our style sheets and in particular will
show up in
our coding when we're actually coding
you will often want to put a
comment there that's only readable by a
human and is not actually processed by
the computer so
this slash star no style used that is
strictly for you as a human being
as far as if this were actually a
cascading style sheet the computer would
be like eh
i'm not paying attention to that that's
for a human i'm not a human i'm a
computer
all right so i've got the paragraph
before i've got the img tag
i've got the paragraph after and as we
can see on our
screenshot on the left this seems to
work right well
there's kind of a problem here it turns
out that if you just put the image by
itself like this
you're going to lose some of your
options most notably the main thing that
you would want to do
with this image is you might want to
center it and it turns out if the img
tag is by itself it cannot be centered
so what you need to do is you actually
need to put a div around the image so
here i've added
a div i've given the different id venice
div
and let's go ahead and add a style to it
i've added this style text align center
and now the image is aligned to the
center
remember if you try and horizontally
align the image by itself
it's not going to work it's going to
turn out we can vertically align the
image i'll show you that in a second but
we cannot horizontally align the image
this is a limitation because it turns
out the img tag itself is
not a block level tag and
the horizontal alignment only works with
block level tags
all right let's take a look at the
vertical alignment now let's go back
to where i had that giant character once
upon a time
so here it is right here this is what we
saw last time i'm going to go ahead and
give it an id
because i want to be able to give it a
style rule and
i've written a style rule for it and
previously the base
of the o basically gigantic o
was aligned with the baseline of the
text
that's sort of the default setting and
now i've told it to vertically align
with the middle and you can see that
i am in fact aligned in the middle
there's also a top
and a bottom vertical alignment you can
play with
so that gives you an idea of what all
your options are for images so go out
and make web pages with lots of colorful
fun
images i'll see in the next video